[Music]
[Applause]
david ferrity who joins us from uh the
old court well no where are you right
now
i'm in the toilet
because
well it's the most spacious area of my
room time here in saint andrews and uh
you know what can you expect for 1500
bucks a night
is it a historical toilet
it's actually very nicely appointed and
it's not the sort of victorian plumbing
that you might expect
it's it's been done up
uh how's the old course going to hold up
this week
you know it depends on the wind and um
which is
you know perhaps i better rephrase that
given where i am
it's uh it has blown pretty strongly
today and if we get that breeze the
crosswinds um it it could hold up pretty
well because it's hard and it's fast um
and that's exactly the way you want to
see saint andrews play it's burned out
in places it's in beautiful condition
but it needs the wind
you remember the last time you played
that course
i remember the last time i played it in
competition yes
how'd you do it
well
i was the captain of the irish side that
won the dunhill cup which was then the
three-man world team championship
and oddly enough
the last time i was in this hotel i was
looking for a ball
um
having won the dunhill cup in 1990 the
irish team collectively decided to play
the last hole at three o'clock in the
morning
and uh i managed to hit it straight
right
off the uh off the 18th tee into the
rusex marine hotel which is where i'm
staying
and broke a window on the ground floor
so that's one of my lasting memories of
andrews
what would be your headline right now
going into the open championship
wow
the headline well you know there's a
couple of players there that uh
you've got to really think about and
will zella taurus is one of them he's
played so incredibly well uh in the
majors
um uh
fitzpatrick matthew fitzpatrick you know
having won the u.s open uh islam but to
be honest i i really like dustin johnson
this week i was watching him on the
range today
and uh he played well the last time out
in the live event and he's he's as
hungry as i've seen him for a long time
you know he fell outside the top 10 in
the world there and he doesn't like that
at all uh he's such a talented player so
long um he's got everything that that a
player would need to win here at saint
andrews
what do you think would be the story or
the fallout if dustin johnson did win
this as a member of the live tour
yeah that's a that's an interesting one
um it's impossible to say uh you know
it has legs
there's no question about that then um
this is a tour that's not gonna go away
um so one way or the other they're going
to have to find a way to deal with it
whether or not you know they incorporate
it into you know where the wraparound
season is or you know
there's been various ideas floated out
um you know to ignore it completely to
incorporate it somehow
uh i you know your guess is as good as
mine on that one it really is up in the
air yeah i just wonder if if can you
embrace it because it feels like they
want to keep taking players away they're
going to go from what eight tour events
to 14 tour events yeah so i it feels
like it's going to be harder to work in
conjunction with the pga tour like a
partnership
well you know we have that wraparound um
series where you know there's about
maybe 16 weeks where the the top events
in the player uh top events are the top
players in the world don't play those
events
so there's that
potential gap in the schedule where you
know this may fit in
um
that's the only possibility i can see
you know when they run uh these events
concurrently with the pga tour and dp
world tour
uh and the other professional tours
around the world
and
i i don't know how that's gonna work
we're talking to david faraday joining
us from uh his bathroom i think you're
sitting on the toilet on the left
uh tiger had this event circled he's won
it twice there why does this course fit
tiger woods
you know and well every course fits
tiger woods but
um i think he just loves it so much
he loves the place uh he fell in love
with it the first time that he played
with it with his father um
it's a it's a magical event
in a magical time and
you know scottish and irish and some
english and welsh golf you know golf in
the british isles they have these
courses where the town has actually
grown up
around the golf course sin andrews is a
really good example of it prestwick is
another um you know where the time
actually wraps its arms around it you
know when somebody says saint andrews
you don't think of the university you
think of the golf course you know and
it's such an integral part of the
culture
um and i think he fell in love with that
the first time he came here and you
bring up a great point you really have
to embrace this kind of style of golf
because if you try to fight it uh it
it's going to come back and bite you
yeah i mean rory mcilroy hated the place
the first time the first time he came
out uh and played here you know and
gradually just grew to love it everyone
who comes here uh if you come here often
enough you know you'll fall in love with
the place there's this kind of a
mystique to san andreas that doesn't
exist anywhere else
you know if you arrive first thing in
the morning you know when there's still
a little mist in the air and the shadows
are filling the the hollows and the
swales and the shadows in the bunkers
whatever it really is you can imagine
that they've been playing golf here
since the 1400s
this golf course was designed by sheep
you once said the world's number one
tennis player spends 90 percent of his
time winning while the world's number
one golfer spends 90 of his time losing
golfers are great losers
do you have to almost i don't know if
it's like a relief pitcher where you may
go in and you may give up a home run and
then you got to come back the next day
like you have to forget about that like
your thoughts on that
you do i i don't think there's another
game that you that forces you to live in
the present more than golf um
it's uh
if you let your mind wander back to what
has happened or if you let your mind
wander forwards to what you hope will
happen
you know you're not paying attention to
the here and now
and it's though those players that that
can you know focus on the space that
they occupy
and and uh
you know concentrate on on just the
actual physical act of whether you know
not not worrying where the ball is going
to go where it might go here it might go
there just pay attention to the actual
act itself
you know and to do that you have to stay
in the present what's the strangest
thing you ever thought of while you were
playing standing over a shot oh
wow that is a large catalog
right there
yeah the strangest thing i ever thought
of
i
i don't know uh there's been a few i
remember standing over a putt to win
um in uh in south africa
uh and uh
i was wondering what my my
at the time wife and my ex-wife thank
you
thank you develop um who's up to
uh
no which uh which wasn't a great thought
and uh i did miss the putt
wait you you were wondering what your
ex-wife was doing at the time perhaps
yes and i was wondering what she was
doing it with
[Laughter]
but she got half of your second place
check didn't she
no she got all of it
uh i did i didn't mean to bum you out i
was just curious if uh
i believe it's the best thing ever
happened to me
she missed the cut
yeah that's right yeah i'm still going
uh what are you doing with these uh
these events these nine hole skin
matches what well what was the uh
genesis for this
well the genesis for it uh you know we
call them the faraday classics which is
massive hyperbole you know for the event
that is it's just nine whole skins game
um and we've just done two of them one
in ottawa with daniel alfredson you know
the ottawa senator legend up there uh
with ben roethlisberger and uh with
emmett smith and then we have ben and
emmett in uh toronto with curtis joseph
and uh we play a nine-hole skins game
we're at 50 000 for charity um i do an
interview on stage
of the four guys pat perez is the pga
tour player and uh it's uh three against
one in the skins game they all try to
beat pat and you know
these are some pretty good players they
have no chance
against a pga tour player in the skins
game uh i think uh of the 18 holes that
we've played so far pat has won 12
or 13
i think it is and uh
and then i drew about 45 minutes of
stand-up uh at the end of the evening so
that's uh
it came to uh about because i did a
similar event with tiger don at blue
jack golf club uh which we think was the
first course that he uh designed and he
and marco mira played a little
exhibition match and i did some
commentary on the golf course you know
with lavalier mics and speakers on cards
so people could hear the banter between
them so it's really been a lot of fun
who was your idol uh
comedy wise growing up do you model
yourself after anybody
uh you know i i'd have to say billy
connolly
uh the great scottish comedian uh if you
google him you know you'll see billy
connolly but also you know george carlin
uh richard pryor uh people that uh
that were on television even when i was
growing up
and uh
i did
my comedy career has has been over the
last seven years uh only uh i never
thought that it would happen uh and i
play you know around 200
gigs now around the country in smaller
theaters to you know cross sort of
between
1500 people and uh around golf
tournaments i try to organize them in
the general vicinity so i've got kind of
a captive audience for uh
the sort of
corporate entertainment that that kind
of event offers
it's great to talk to you hope you're
doing well and uh
be on your best behavior
uh you know what then thanks buddy
thank you buddy and flush
yeah hang on
oh no it's a floater
thank you david
see you bud
thanks buddy see you soon i hope
that might be a first
i'm guessing